Тільки-но "приміряв" президентське крісло, як одразу заявив:
Я от дивлюсь і думаю: так коли ми переїжджаємо?
Бажання переїхати з будівлі Адміністрації президента
Володимир Зеленський висловив одразу - ще в деньсвоєї інавгурації.
І от рівно через місяцьйого команда презентує не лише план реорганізації самої структури.
А показує, як виглядатиме новий Офіс президента,
який збираються перенести в будівлю Українського дому в Києві.
Також ми маємо два варіанти, де може знаходитись Ваш кабінет.
Це перший варіант, коли ви дивитесь на Європейську площу.
Це другий варіант, коли ви дивитесь на Дніпро.
Що буде з нинішньою будівлею Адміністрації президента, реформатори також вже вирішили.
Для чого це місце, де ми з тобою знаходимось? Для великого музею!
Монументальну будівлю на Банковій, 11 впізнає кожен українець.
До незалежності тут був Центральний комітет комуністичної партії України.
А після 91 року - указом Леоніда Кравчука- розмістилась Адміністрація президента.
Працівники будівлі з гордістю розповідають про неї.
Вона дуже широченна, масивна, масштабна, але наскільки талановитий архітектор.
Ця будівля, вона не давить!
Але так думають далеко не всі.
В масивній шестиповерховій споруді працювали усі шість президентів України,
з них двоє - Петро Порошенко і Володимир Зеленський -
публічно заявляли про наміри переїхати.
Ви розумієте, чому я хочу переїхати. Я не можу тут нормально жити.
Перший поверх - для роботи журналістів. До другого ведуть просторі, втім темні коридори.
Тут у залі державних заходів приймають іноземні делегації та відбуваються засідання РНБО.
У кабінетах мінімум природного світла - максимум коштовних люстр та позолоти.
І те, що гарно виглядає на фото під час урочистих зустрічей,
в повсякденному житті нових працівників Адміністрації пригнічує.
Я мистецтвознавець за освітою, театрознавець, кінознавець, точніше.
На старих декораціях важко ставити нову виставу.
Мені здається, що це досить урочистий декор, досить пафосний, але не дуже сучасний.
Якщо ми хочемо будувати сучасну країну, то треба трохи оновити.
Кожен президент робив в Адміністрації ремонт, так би мовити, під себе.
Помпезності тут побільшало за часів президента-втікача Віктора Януковича.
Коли Юлія Мендель - новопризначена речниця глави держави -
вперше переступила поріг будівлі, одразу згадала про "Межигір’я".
Ну, і справді. Позолота, дуже багато мармуру, враження такого розкішного, помпезного, золотого,
і тут прийшов Володимир Зеленський на інтерв’ю в джинсов ому костюмі, тому що це була субота.
Він не дуже вписувався, бо він почувався дуже розкуто,
він був такий відкритий, а вся ця помпезність доволі тиснула.
Втім будівля Адміністрації -це не лише стіни, ширина яких подекуди один метр.
Це, в першу чергу, безпека. Як фізична, так і інформаційна. На 4-му поверсі чергова перевірка.
Працівники УДО просять залишити телефони та годинники. Тут знаходиться кабінет президента.
Зеленський за робочим столом спершу показує, яким, за його словами, "айфоном"
він користується для оперативного зв’язку з міністрами та іншими топ-чиновниками.
Баканов, Аваков, Князєв, бачите, деяких людей немає, а кнопочки залишились. Ось Гройсман є!
Далі веде до наступної кімнати. Тут президента готують до публічних виступів.
Кімната нагадує персональну перукарню.
Все працює!
Побачити спортзал, масажний кабінет та басейн журналістам не вдалось.
А от пообідати в їдальні за дуже помірними цінами, за бажання, змогли б.
Для першої і другої страв, та ще й десерту достатньо ста гривень.
У нинішній будівлі Адміністрації президента 195 кабінетів, і працює тут понад 400 людей.
До Українського дому переїдуть не всі - нова команда вже оголосила про скорочення штату.
Як буде реалізовуватись переїзд з презентаційного відео поки не зрозуміло.
Так само як і те, скільки це коштуватиме, і де візьмуть гроші.
Ми знайшли концепцію, що ми ні копійки не будемо витрачати з бюджету країни. Концепція хороша.
Також не відомо, як забезпечуватимуть конфіденційність
роботи глави держави в омріяному ореn space.
Приміром, для засідань РНБО, які мають статус "дуже секретно",
повинні бути створені спеціальні умови.
Адже йдеться про питання безпеки країни.